y los mensajes de auxilio de louis
michel
el barco financiado por el artista
británico banksy fueran finalmente
escuchados una guardia costera italiana
acudió al rescate de 49 de las personas
más vulnerables el sábado y el resto de
los migrantes a bordo unas 150 personas
fueron recibidos por un barco de la ong
alemanas y watch y la organización
médicos sin fronteras están esperando a
bordo del numeral sy watch para que se
les asigne un lugar seguro numeral louis
michel ya no tiene huéspedes a bordo
pero la lucha de los sobrevivientes no
ha terminado el louis michel de bandera
alemana anunció el viernes que estaba a
barrado y que necesitaba ayuda urgente
después de encontrarse con una
embarcación precaria que transportaba al
menos un migrante muerto si watch 4 que
tiene una clínica a bordo dijo que
decidió actuar ante la falta de reacción
de las autoridades ahora está buscando
un puerto de acogida
para aquellos embarcados más
recientemente la evaluación médica está
en curso con la clínica llena médicos
sin fronteras tratando a las personas
por quemaduras de combustible
deshidratación hipotermia y lesiones
traumáticas los migrantes rescatados
dijeron más tarde que tres personas
habían muerto en el mar antes de la
llegada de louis michel
este año se estima que al menos 300
personas perdieron la vida en el viaje a
través del mediterráneo' para huir de
los conflictos la represión y la pobreza
en áfrica y el oriente medio